cette nuit la fin de la rn9 s'est encore
agrandie tous les services de la ctm
sont mobilisés ces thèmes et ville de
fort de france sont sur le pont pour
suivre son évolution et c'est cette
portion de la route derrière la copie
tonnes qui fait aujourd'hui l'objet de
toutes les attentions
si la pluie se poursuit comme il ya
toujours où l'eau souterraine plus
l'appui il ya un risque le talus
s'écroule parce que nous avons observée
hier soir que rich man avait progressé
il peut avoir un effet d'accélération dû
au fait que la pluie continue et va
évidemment modifier le sol
la ctm souhaite la fermer mais sa
gestion est du ressort de la ville de
fort de france qui elle a déjà donné son
accord et anticiper la prochaine
fermeture là aujourd'hui on est en train
de regarder avec des techniciennes a
cité m
ce quelle portion de voie l'initiateur
de fermer pour assurer la sécurité de
ceux qui fréquentent le centre d'olivier
auch
là nous sommes en train de regarder
comment réaliser l'accès du chantier
pour que la fermeture soit effective
l'impact économique générée par cette
faille est énorme pour les commerces et
le trafic
financièrement parlant le coup de sac et
options est aussi conséquents et la ctm
cherche à identifier des responsables et
les distributeurs d'eau est salée
propriétaire du réseau privé louga la
fuite chance les constructeurs des
immeubles autour de l'échangeur nous
mettrons des mises en cause ça c'est sur
le plan judiciaire nous avons c'est
quelqu'un qui est très long mais notre
devoir c'est de protéger les ressources
des contribuables ce que les fonds que
nous avons des frais des contribuables
et ça prendra du temps mais trop tard
dumas valoir de la justice dès qu'ils le
responsable d'établissement de l'eau
continue de s'écouler en grande quantité
dans les dres talent et la faille
elle continue de s'agrandir les travaux
seront donc l'ont aussi une nouvelle
déviation doit être bientôt mise en
place